giving you some way in balance Middleton
step back
yes
they'll off the basketball before the
red light comes on
[Applause]
yes he did I told you it was good Wow
[Applause]
recaptures the trouble we're to shoot
[Applause]
you are a cheat code over the end of
rule the quick shot to hit the glass and
went in
[Applause]
[Music]
and he matches his Oh job to corral
Simmons and State for the Sixers attempt
to the past break hands we're just
talking about
and beach somehow kept his pivot foot
Wow and Simmons to beneficiaries just a
few clicks ago Jojo going right at
defenders nice ballads allows someone to
do that he's good enough in the face of
John Collins here's the replay good fall
a little bit pump fake where's up on the
honesty honest tight together love
forcing to throw away let's oh yeah
that's done
like it does
[Music]
third quarter a scout
[Music]
since Yanis trilling siakam not quitting
on the play and it's not in been stuck
on yogic and Beadle is a six is
scrambling now beat as Millsap was going
for the glory on the other end they go
to court Moz Vince game three dips in
and stretched oh here's that last
exchange in Oh think again Jo Ellen be
the last line of defense
long on us on down to the ground off the
ball on the weak side
there's Paul involved in that Chris Paul
Josh takes it away ahead for heel back
for Yanis what up guys our side of the
combo and George Hill beautiful
basketball first the great defensive
play give me that cp3
get it early get it back watch that
bounce pass no-look number from George
Hill and then get out the way in fact
boy swayin
monster jam mean before 55 left backdoor
cut jeans stop to go
denied by Pascal Davis grabs it
Davis driving to the Rama another take
away Levine knife through soft butter
right about that
[Music]
[Applause]
hammer
[Music]
here's a little baseline pop shot that
goes watch Trey look at Ricky right
through the legs that's just that's a
signature move right there and Baines
what are you doing 610 611 guy you got a
challenge something not going to get
away - 924 Milwaukee it's exciting when
there are multiple teams do oh my
that's exciting every night of the
season I mean look there's no way the
times he could had any idea was about to
happen it's been a very solid second
game as a blazer for Carmelo Anthony ten
point lead
oh man look at this play baseline spin
reverse dunk ray waits at mid floor now
gets into it with five four from the
logo yes
[Music]
[Applause]
right behind the back to Parker what a
pass well how he was able to turn the
corner
oh nice behind the back pass right on
cue Simmons to the cutting Harris
tonight
[Applause]
Thomas Jefferson wakes it up and you
know where does it all start the
defensive end looks like an easy to four
hairs at Pascal
[Applause]
[Music]
judging that appraise will look back on
the comeuppance for here Fred Tyson 11.5
Pacer timeout penis blows by Matthew
Brogdon on a nice crossover between the
legs he goes up there the challenge
there by sabonis too late
[Music]
21 fourth-quarter points for a young
when is it anybody to lead and they have
the worst defensive google percentage at
that range also so it's definitely an
area
those you're on a set you know Russians
I know how to get those back and he does
it's twelve five but walking bleeding
New York
[Applause]
17 points here he comes yes
backside clear it out and then this one
here man
just us still in that play able to come
up with it inside and be knees deep
[Applause]
I almost didn't think he would get it
off that file there by a grin man trying
to go back to turn strips
[Applause]
oh no he's fast the whole at the 50 fast
like a look like off the transition
there's Kimmel Walker drivin dumps it
lay and Jalen Brown with a 360 Jam that
fast break brought to you by FiOS by
Verizon one to two Connaughton Jana
she's a three man defensive law
Milton back - yes
here's Janice right here you talk about
that wall where here's a little
Wallbanger name ain't Harvey Pascale
short and a long rebound and taken down
by Brooklyn here we go
spices be
[Applause]
off to the races see ACTA with three
blocks tonight many tickets remaining
for that game tomorrow night
so get on
great deep fat Swedish to that George
Hill
a hammer walker little dance man goes by
whose big shots by the Celtics at the
end of the first and second court even
Chen Zoe's not giving Dante his first
points in the game
[Applause]
and again in the saddle kits in Old Town
Road conquered the Kray walk three pulls
off time on Boston 311 to play map tips
on the gaskets through the lane bounced
to the cutting peppery picked up through
toe out to dre long Bob from that car
and
holiday is in the lane the best shooters
out there in the middle of the floor
that's adjust and there's nobody out
there I mean here all day to shoot this
like three or four shots Alex laughs or
pass by fries you set in the screen here
little brush man he rolls right down to
Benson but that pass was between Yogi's
legs what a bad for trying to get
organized defensively Morristown oh the
back and lays it in
[Applause]
that's what folks this is a plus you
don't get any better than this
right between the late oh here we go off
the glass and in
[Applause]
man just a beautiful beautiful
one-on-one move their courageous what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content